und jetzt das heute journal
mit heinz wolf und marietta slomka guten
abend der ganze wahnsinn die ungeheure
fahrlässigkeit die darin lag ein
hochkomplexes thema das für mehr als
eine nation gravierende folgen hat in
eine grob vereinfachende emotionale ja
nein frage zu gießen
das lästig seit nunmehr drei jahren in
großbritannien beobachten so lange schon
versucht das land verzweifelt
herauszufinden was für ein boxset denn
überhaupt gemeint war
das volk hat diese frage nicht
beantwortet sie wurde ihm ja auch gar
nicht gestellt
das parlament schafft es nicht sie zu
beantworten weil es keine einigung
findet dieses drama erschüttert jetzt
auch noch die grundfeste des britischen
regierungssystems jene ungeschriebene
balance zwischen parlament und regierung
auf die britannien immer stolz war die
prämie boris johnson will jetzt
erzwingen was die volksvertretung eben
nicht gibt aus london jetzt den herrlein
[Applaus]
vielleicht gibt es ja den einen oder
anderen der das vermisst hat die
nächtelangen schlachten im parlament von
denen es vor der sommerpause dieses jahr
ja so viele gegeben hatte er sollte auf
seine kosten kommt mit jeder menge drama
gleich zu beginn der herr im blauen
anzug der da in begleitung zweier
liberaldemokraten auf den
oppositionsbänken platz nimmt ist ein
ehemaliger konservative verblüfft
beobachtete johnson die szene mit diesem
partei übertritt hat er seine mehrheit
im parlament verloren
dies ist eine ernste angelegenheit aber
ich habe manchmal den eindruck dass die
regierung das alles als spiel ansieht
doch hier geht es um das wohlergehen und
die zukunft von menschen deshalb habe
ich die seiten gewechselt
der widerstand gegen ein no deal braig
sieht formiert sich dabei sind die
oppositionsparteien auf die hilfe von
abtrünnigen tories angewiesen johnson
hatte den parteimitgliedern die gegen
ihn stimmen würden mit
fraktionsausschluss gedroht und damit
sie bei den kommenden wahl nicht mehr
als kandidaten aufzustellen
da wird der ehemalige finanzminister
philip hammond typ besonnener buchhalter
plötzlich zum rebellen
ich fühle auch nicht als empörung
darüber dass die partei der ich seit 45
jahren angehört mich rausschmeißen will
und jenen leuten die unsere partei
gekapert haben spreche ich das recht ab
dies zu entscheiden
exit das war von anfang an der innere
streit der konservativen über europa
jetzt droht die endgültige spaltung die
opposition sieht darin ihre chance
johnson macht sich keine freunde in
europa und er verliert sie hier zuhause
dies ist eine regierung ohne mandat ohne
moral und seit heute ohne mehrheit
und der premierminister ganz boris
johnson scheut sich nicht auf weltkriegs
vokabular zurückzugreifen
ich nenne diese gesetzesvorlage dass
jeremy coping kapitulation gesetz er
winkt mit der weißen fahne nach brüssel
alles was die opposition will ist mich
zu zwingen dort um eine weitere sinnlose
verlängerung zu betteln vermutlich kann
man über solcherlei nur lachen wenn man
nicht mehr die verantwortung trägt
die nudel gegner sind sich sicher dass
sie genug stimmen haben die regierung zu
besiegen was dann kommt müssen
wahrscheinlich die wenigsten die hier
heute wieder eine denkwürdige parlaments
schlacht geschlagen haben
ja in der tat ein hochdramatischer
machtkampf diana zimmermann in london
gibt's da wetten wie das ausgeht
also was man glaube ich sagen kann ist
dass die rebellen optimistisch sind dass
sie die zahlen zusammen haben nicht nur
hat das parlament hier ja schon in der
vergangenheit klar gemacht dass es den
chaotischen braig cit nicht will das
gebaren dass boris johnson an den tag
legt bringt selbst sonst sehr geduldige
konservativer auf die palme also die
chancen dafür dass das parlament die
abstimmung heute und morgen im sinne der
opposition entscheidet stehen gut aber
was dann
johnston hat er gesagt wenn das so ist
dann möchte er neuwahl noch vor dem 31
oktober nun ist es aber so dass die
opposition misstraut und befürchtet er
könnte diese neuwahlen doch noch
irgendwie dafür nutzen den audi lbr exit
durchzuziehen und deswegen wird die
opposition und die rebellen der
konservativen diesem antrag von ihm
eventuell nicht zustimmen
das misstrauen dass ich hier ausdrückt
gegenüber johnson scheint tatsächlich
historisch tiefen der stichwort
historisch gab es das eigentlich
überhaupt schon mal dass ein premier
somit dem parlament aneinandergeraten
ist die parallele die hier alle ziehen
ist die zu könig karl dem ersten der in
siebzehnten jahrhundert das parlament
auflöste weil es nicht so wollte wie er
wollte die steuern erhöhen um seine
feldzüge zu finanzieren das parlament
sagte nein das ganze endete übrigens in
elf jahren diktatur und einem
bürgerkrieg die andere parallelen sind
natürlich die zu populisten allgemein
johnston stellt sicher da als alleiniger
vertreter des wählerwillens er
argumentiert 17 millionen briten hätten
für den bhc rexit gestimmt dabei
unterschlägt er nicht nur die 16
millionen die dagegen gestimmt haben
sondern vor allem dass er selbst in der
kampagne ja damals gesagt hat ist
kinderleicht einen super deal mit der eu
zu bekommen
von einem chaos bei exeter damals so
recht nicht die rede und jetzt sagt er
immer noch es sei ganz leicht für ihn
einen viel besseren deal mit der eu zu
bekommen wäre da bloß nicht das
parlament seinen eigenen abgeordneten
drohte jetzt damit sie rauszuschmeißen
und insgesamt ist das ganze entweder
kühn oder dreist auf jeden fall aber ist
es sehr gefährlich sowohl für die
demokratie als auch für den premier
selbst
sie werden das heute abend weiter
beobachten da geht es dann nach wie vor
hoch her im parlament und wenn der neue
entscheidungen fallen dann schalten wir
noch mal nach london
diana danke so weit erst mal blicken wir
auf die deutsche politik die wahlen in
sachsen und brandenburg haben natürlich
nach wien und verlangen nach
nachbetrachtungen im vordergrund der
analysen standen seit dem wahlabend
natürlich einerseits die enormen
zuwächse der afd
auf der anderen seite das abschneiden
der jeweiligen regierungsparteien cdu
und spd die sich in den nächsten wochen
nun eine mehrheit zusammen basteln
müssen was angesichts der
stimmenverluste nicht leicht wird aber
es gab ja noch mehr verlierer und
enttäuschte einfach an die linke die so
massiv abgesackt ist das hier schon
bescheinigt wird nicht länger
volkspartei des ostens zu sein
lange gesichter gab es aber auch bei der
fdp schaffte ja noch nicht mal den
einzug in die landtage beide parteien
scheinen regelrecht verdrängt zu werden
damit beschäftigt sich christian von
rechenberg
was ist da passiert linke und fdp vom
wähler umgeblasen abgestellt kann weg
die afg für die opposition im bund
sowieso und nun auch in fünf landtagen
man stellt sich fragen heute in potsdam
der landesvorstand der linken hält
scherbengericht in brandenburg wohl raus
aus der regierung und dann nicht mal
stärkste opposition erfolg hatte die afg
ängste bedient einfache lösungen
aufgetischt sagen nicht wie sie es
machen aber sie vermitteln das gefühl
dass sie teil dieser frustration sind
und das ist etwas was uns als linke
wahrscheinlich in den vergangenen jahren
nicht mehr so gelungen ist zu sagen auch
wir sind frustriert über bestimmte
entscheidungen die auf bundesebene
getroffen worden sind und die immer noch
verhindern dass es eine wirkliche
einheit in deutschland gibt allein im
saarland führt die linken auch die
opposition wie auferstehen aus ruinen
neuaufstellung eine botschaft der
bundesspitze eine andere
es gibt keinen liebesentzug die wahl war
taktisch
also ich habe das selber in sachsen
immer wieder erlebt inhalte super ich
bin inhaltlich bei euch aber bei dieser
wahl jetzt nur darum zu verhindern dass
die fdp in die regierung kommen deswegen
wähle ich jetzt union
es kommt wohl noch einiges mehr hinzu
auch ein selbst schuld von der fraktions
chefin sahra wagenknecht wenn wir
menschen jenseits des hippen großstadt
milieus erreichen wollen müssen wir ihre
sicht der dinge ernst nehmen statt sie
zu belehren wie sie zu reden und zu
denken haben protest ansaugen das sagt
sich so leicht afd wahlkämpfen gelingt
der fdp chef hat damit ein problem da
gab es eine höhere dosierung von
opposition die uns als einer
bürgerlichen seriösen gestaltungspartei
aber nicht zur verfügung steht das ist
nicht unser er hat war
da können wir nicht im wettbewerb 1
wolfgang kubicki scheint das anders zu
sehen
der passauer neuen presse sagte er wir
müssen offener und kommunikativer mit
der afg und ihren wählerinnen und
wählern umgehen nicht immer alles
automatisch als rechtsradikal
brandmarken was einem nicht gefällt
zustimmung aus rheinland-pfalz ich halte
es für einen fehler dass man die
wählerinnen und wähler der afg dafür
beschimpft wir müssen sie mit einem
konstruktiven klaren politikangebot
wieder für uns zurückzugewinnen
zurückgewinnen so klingt auch aus china
wo der fdp fraktions vorstand kriegsrat
hält wieder keinen fuß in einen landtag
der neuen bundesländer gebracht was mag
da helfen wir als liberale sollten uns
mehr darum kümmern die beweggründe
derjenigen die als dw
selbst zu übernehmen und auch deren
gedanken wären entscheidungen mit zu
vollziehen weil ich nicht im radikalen
stile einer afd
ein gedanke der bleibt jedenfalls hält
die fdp in jener morgen genau hier ihren
zukunftskongress aber ich hab das wollen
wir noch etwas näher analysieren dafür
ist der politikwissenschaftler professor
karl rudolf korte von der universität
duisburg bei uns im studio die landkarte
ja die fdp tut sich schwer im osten fuß
zu fassen woran liegt das ihrer
einschätzung noch einmal spezieller von
diesen waren rahmenbedingungen wir haben
ein oppositions markt der entstanden ist
der auch polarisiert ist wie die wiener
märkte insgesamt zwischen der frage
afg und grüne vor allen dingen als
antipoden und wer gewinnt das
schlussrennen afd oder die
regierungspartei setzt ministerpräsident
und da bleibt die fdp wie andere
parteien komplett erst mal auf der
strecke dann ist das ja nicht nur ein
regionales phänomen sondern die fdp
steht ja auch bundesweit nicht so da wie
sie sich das mal erhofft hat also die
europawahl war ziemlich katastrophal mit
5,4 prozent
was ist passiert seit der bundestagswahl
das jamaica aushängt der partei ganz
offensichtlich nach eine partei die
gerne von wählerinnen unterstützt wird
und wählern die marktwirtschaftliche
konzepte antworten konstruktive art
mitregieren mit steuern angreifen
erwarten können nicht verzeihen dass man
in einer entscheidungssituation sagt ich
mache nicht mit das hängt bis heute nach
und dann ist in oppositions gebaren des
oppositions marktes auch kein richtiger
platz um dort im bundestag so
aufzutreten dass man auch als
alleinstellungsmerkmal besonders wird
das hat die fdp wohl gedacht dass sie
das hinbekommt ich werde oppositions
markt den begriff den sie verwenden
liegt mir doch noch mal auf die linke
die jetzt bei diesen beiden
landtagswahlen eigentlich mehr verloren
hat als alle anderen hier wirklich
massiv abgesagt was ist da geschehen ist
oder sie von der afg verdrängt die ja
weil die opposition die die rebellion
farbe hat praktisch gewechselt von rot
auf blau weil wir eine art von
kooperativer opposition haben die in
einer umarmung schlichtungs demokratie
in der wir sind im bund
das rad auch mit regiert in vier
landesregierung einen
ministerpräsidenten stellt da ist nichts
fundamental gegensätzliches wäre wenn
man etwas oppositions rebellen haft
ausdrücken möchte dass es bei der after
fd offenbar klarer transparenter zu
sehen und in der mit
regierungsverantwortung hat man sie
nicht gesehen weil man gesehen hat da
stärken wir lieber den
ministerpräsidenten in seiner partei
sonst wird die afg zu stark ist denn
damit jetzt sozusagen die afg die neue
protestpartei des ostens geworden oder
ist der begriff protestpartei überhaupt
gar nicht so mehr zu treffen
sie ist so eine sammlungsbewegung sie
hat protest akteure aber sie ist auch
eine partei vor allen dingen in sachsen
die durchaus auch ein inhaltliches
profil mit anbieten möchte ganz offenbar
ein weniger weniger europäisch weniger
offen weniger unterschiedlich und das
hat sie eben von den grünen vor allen
dingen besonders unterschieden dass es
durchaus eine programmatische ansage die
wählerinnen und wähler mit dieser partei
sicher hoffen auch als oppositionspartei
das gab es ja auch mit blick zum
beispiel auf sachsen und eine ganz
interessante umfragen gestern dann auch
vorgestern auch bei dem am wahlabend
dass zum beispiel in sachsen weit über
70 prozent der fdp wähler seien
es ging jetzt gar nicht mehr darum hier
irgendwem einen denkzettel zu verpassen
sondern ich finde inhalte also nicht nur
unmut auf sauger nicht nur ideologisch
rechtsrucks und natürlich aus auch ein
angebot inhaltlicher art dass es aber
die positive botschaft im
parteienwettbewerb für die anderen
partei denn wenn man weiß was man will
kann man damit auch mit anderen darüber
spreche man kann argumentieren man kann
zuhören und versuchen zu überzeugen
wenn man nur mit einer front
konfrontiert ist die sagt nein überhaupt
nicht fundamental dagegen gibt es
überhaupt keine möglichkeit zum gespräch
also das angebot zu suchen bietet die
möglichkeit für die anderen diese lücke
auch mit aufzufüllen sagt
politikwissenschaftler professor karten
gern online auf heute de finden sie noch
weitere hintergründe zu den
landtagswahlen in sachsen und
brandenburg und natürlich auch alle
zahlen und jetzt erstmal die nachricht
vom 12 langsam und nach wie vor
bedrohlich bewegt sich hurrikan orient
jetzt von den bahamas richtung norden
und damit richtung
küste der genaue weg damit wie sehr er
die us küstengebiete trifft ist noch
unklar
auf den bahamas hatte der hurrikan mit
extremer woche tobt mit
windgeschwindigkeiten von fast 300
kilometern pro stunde mindestens fünf
menschen sind ums leben gekommen
der sturm hat überflutungen verursacht
häuser und autos zerstört
derzeit hat sich der harry kennt
abgeschwächt wird in der kategorie 2 von
5 eingestuft aber das bedeutet immer
noch windgeschwindigkeiten bis zu 175
kilometer pro stunde gut zwei wochen
bevor in berlin das klima kabinett der
großen koalition über die maßnahmen zum
klimaschutz berät hat die union heute
über ihr konzept dazu beraten bei der
cdu gab es ein werkstattgespräch juni
über vorschläge diskutiert wurde und die
csu-landesgruppe präsentierte ihr
konzept das sie bei einer klausurtagung
verabschiedet hat geeinigt haben sich
cdu und csu unter anderem schon auf eine
ausweitung des co2 emissionshandels auf
verkehr und gebäude ebenso auf einen
ausbau des öffentlichen nahverkehrs und
eine erhöhung der pendlerpauschale
in italien wird eine regierungskoalition
aus fünf sterne bewegung und
sozialdemokraten immer wahrscheinlicher
die fünf sterne mitglieder haben bei
einer online-abstimmung zu fast 80
prozent für ein solches bündnis gestimmt
regierungschef soll wieder der
parteilose joe sakic konnte werden er
war nach dem bruch der bisherigen
koalition aus fünf sterne und
rechtspopulistischer leger
zurückgetreten
die holocaust-überlebende lasker
wallfisch ist von bundespräsident
steinmeier mit dem deutschen
nationalpreis geehrt worden
stein mal würde ich dir bemühen um
verständigung und ihr eintreten gegen
juden hast die 94 jährige anita lasker
wallfisch überlebte die
vernichtungslager auschwitz und bergen
belsen als musikerin im frauen orchester
seit 1994 spricht sie über diese zeit
mit schülern in deutschland in
nordhessen sind beim absturz einer
wartungs gondel drei menschen ums leben
gekommen
die gondel stürzte mit den drei
arbeitern 50 meter in die tiefe
unglücksursache könnten probleme mit der
seilwinde gewesen sein
die anlage gehört im hessischen rundfunk
eine firma sollte eine neue antenne auf
dem sendemast montieren
der kleine tiergarten ein park in berlin
moabit ist nicht gerade das was man als
eine heile welt gegend bezeichnet würde
als dort vor einer woche einen mann am
helllichten tage erschossen wurde konnte
man erst mal vermuten dass es um
kriminalität womöglichen drogen bildung
geht dann kam heraus dass das mordopfer
eine zeit lang als islamistische
gefährder geführt wurde
auch das schien auf den ersten blick
noch ins bild zu passen
moabit hat eine islamistenszene doch
inzwischen gehen die ermittlungen in
eine ganz andere richtung der tote ist
georgi der festgenommene tatverdächtige
offenbar ein russe nach recherchen des
spiegel und weitere medien soll erst
kürzlich mit falschen pass eingereist
sein und verbindungen zum russischen
geheimdienst tagen wurde hier etwa auf
deutschem boden ein staatlicher
auftragsmord durchgeführt das wäre
allerdings ungeheuerlich und würde die
beziehungen zu moskau und noch mehr
belasten als sie das e schutz sind
kristiansand berichtet dass dies ein
ungewöhnlicher mordfall ist war schnell
klar der mörder kam mit dem fahrrad das
opfer zu fuß unterwegs zwei gezielte
kopfschüsse mit schalldämpfer mitten in
berlin der mutmaßliche täter flüchtet
schmeißt eine perücke und das fahrrad in
die spree später wird er festgenommen
und schweigt seitdem die polizei möchte
natürlich durch die veröffentlichung
dieses bildes des beschuldigten
erkenntnisse über diesen mann gewinnen
das heißt haben zeugen ihn gesehen haben
sie ihn vielleicht gekannt können sie
irgendwelche angaben dazu machen weil
sich aufgehalten hat er ist das opfer
des mordanschlags selim kann rango
schwille 41 jahre alt an aus georgien
stammende schiene im tschetschenien
krieg kämpfte er gegen das russische
militär als anhänger einer
rebellengruppe zwei mordanschläge
überlebt er bereits beantragte 2016 asyl
in deutschland
der erste mord versucht gegen francos
will lieber 2008 beim nächsten versuch
2015 in tiflis hat er nur überlebt weil
ein krankenhaus in der nähe war
jetzt ist es in berlin passiert er war
offensichtlich ein ziel für die leute
die die schritt für schritt
schlüsselfiguren töten die
tschetschenien verlassen haben
vieles deutet hin auf einen auftragsmord
journalisten vom netzwerk berlin kat von
d insider und vom spiegel haben
recherchiert der täter soll mit einem
gefälschten russischen pass unterwegs
gewesen sein
darin ein schengen visum für frankreich
im juli ausgestellt auf den namen war
dem zocalo wohnort st petersburg wir
haben den namen durch alle möglichen
russischen datenbanken gejagt und zu
unserer überraschung fanden wir heraus
dass es diese person nicht gibt weder in
den online noch in den offline
datenbanken hesse autoversicherung flüge
als hätte diese person nie existiert der
pass sei sehr schnell ausgestellt worden
ohne biometrische daten
die journalisten sind sich sicher dass
es eine verbindung zu russischen
geheimdiensten gibt der russische
geheimdienst hat dem mann geholfen aus
russland auszureisen
wir kennen solche fälle aus früheren
anderen recherchen
am flughafen trifft man einen beamten
des geheimdienstes fsb mit dem man das
übliche prozedere umgeht
wir nehmen an dass genau das passiert
ist sonst wäre es unmöglich ein visum
für so einen pass zu kriegen oder
auszureisen
der kreml bestreitet jegliche verbindung
zu dem mordfall in deutschland hat der
generalbundesanwalt die ermittlungen
noch nicht an sich gezogen was darauf
hindeutet dass entscheidende hinweise
noch fehlen die journalisten vom insider
sagen sie wollen bald weitere details
veröffentlichen
15 braucht jetzt noch mal weiter und
stadt geht der blick zunächst noch mal
nach großbritannien und die ja noch
läuft diese turbulente parlamentssitzung
und noch ist nicht abzusehen
wir sind boksic streit weiter geht die
britische währung das pfund fiel heute
zeitweise auf den tiefsten wert
gegenüber dem dollar seit fast drei
jahren von bethmann wie sehen die
finanzmärkte und die wirtschaft
insgesamt die lage im moment ja heute
hatten wir mal wieder sehr gut sehen
können dass eine währung ein gutes
stimmungsbarometer sein kann dann nach
dem johnson seine mehrheit im unterhaus
verloren hatte erholte sich das pfund
sterling umgehend sofort wurde wieder
leichte hoffnung an den devisenmärkten
gehandelt vielleicht kann ja einen exit
chaos doch noch vermieden werden denn
zuletzt insbesondere nachdem im märz das
britische parlament den austritts
vertrag mit der eu ein drittes mal
abgelehnt hatte verlor die britische
währung doch massiv an wert ein no
brachse deal könnte großbritannien in
die rezession stürzen das ist die
befürchtung die im kursverfall abzulesen
ist immer öfter hört man aus der
britischen wirtschaft auf ein modell
soll man auch gar nicht ausreichend
vorbereitet
anleger und investoren haben längst
reagiert und sich von der insel
zurückgezogen so gesehen sorgte das
neuerliche hin und her in london hier
auf dem parkett heute für keine
aufregung der dax verliert nur moderat
43 punkte oder knapp 0,4 prozent der
vertrauensschaden der ist längst
entstanden von einem schwächelnden pfund
können die briten noch nicht einmal groß
profitieren weil sie im export nicht
besonders stark sind so gesehen spiegelt
sich in erwägung derzeit einfach nur die
schwäche des landes wieder frank
wittmann
vielen dank die deutschen basketballer
sind bei der wm in china bereits in der
vorrunde gescheitert
gegen die dominikanische republik liegt
das team wie schon gegen frankreich
einen fehlstart hin
er kämpft sich aber bis zur halbzeit
wieder einen knappen vorsprung mit 39 37
mit einzelaktionen die hier von nba
profi dennis schröder fällt sich
deutschland lange im spiel
am ende aber geht auch dieses zweite
gruppenspiel mit 68 zu 70 knapp verloren
die enttäuschung groß die deutschen
fußball frauen konnten im em
qualifikationsspiel heute gegen die
ukraine eine deutlich positive bilanz
für sich verbuchen acht tore und drei
punkte
dominant und sehr präsent die deutsche
elf kleine schwächen in defensive und
chancenverwertung fallen nicht ins
gewicht
sara däbritz stellt nach vier minuten
die weichen
dina magull und felicitas rauch sorgen
zur pause für 1 3 zu 0 für die
mannschaft von martina voss-tecklenburg
in der zweiten halbzeit dann die
torpremiere der 17 jahre alte
abwehrspielerin li na oberdorf und vier
weitere treffer in der schlussphase der
brits dabei mit ihren toren zwei und
drei
als letzter höhepunkt leonie maier s 8
zu 0 gegen einen biederen gegner
[Applaus]
das war es von uns weiter geht es mit
der reportage reihe 37° heute über
menschen mit dem sogenannten messie
syndrom um 0 uhr dann heute plus daniel
brack auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
die liebe zu schauerwetter kann auch wie
gemalt aussehen und morgen gibt es eben
sonne und regen bei uns denn von westen
nähert sich dieses tiefdruckgebiet mit
seinen fronten
es wird morgen dann den norden und
westen mit kräftigen schauern
beeinflussen und dahinter ab donnerstag
wird es von nordwesten deutlich kühler
werden
heute nacht in den nächsten stunden gibt
es eigentlich nur noch örtlich ein paar
schauer direkt an den küsten ansonsten
bleibt es trocken es gibt nebelfelder
und es wird klar im süden und das
bedeutet es geht runter mit der
temperatur morgen früh vier bis neun
grad deutlich milder mit bis zu 15 grad
ist es an den küsten ja morgen scheint
dann erst einmal die sonne aber in
norddeutschland nehmen die wolken
schnell vom westen zu und dann ab mittag
gibt es erste kräftige regenschauer vom
niederrhein bis zur nordseeküste
nachmittags kommen die schauer langsam
nach osten voran lübecker bucht
niedersachsen bis zur eifel etwa aber
sonst nach osten hin und süden da bleibt
es trocken
es ist sehr windig in norddeutschland
auch stürmisch und sturmböen kann es aus
südwesten an der nordsee geben die
temperaturen dann dort so von der ostsee
bis zum niederrhein etwa 18 bis 22 grad
aber im osten und süden 24 bis 28 oder
sogar 29 grad
das war es kann man sagen dann kommt
dieses wetter mit mehr schauern mit
kühler luft am donnerstag
und die wird sich weiterhin über
deutschland ausbreiten samstag mit
schauern und gewittern 14 bis 19 grad ja
hurrikan dorian in der karibik ist nicht
der einzige wirbelsturm es gibt auch ein
am pazifik der sich gebildet hat aber
raus aufs wasser zieht der ist nicht
mehr so sehr gefährlich ja auch diese
tropischen stürme hier im golf von
mexiko sind aktiv ja und dorian selber
der hat sich eben seit sozusagen
anderthalb tagen überhaupt nicht mehr
bewegt es geht immer weiter dort dreht
sich zunächst ist auch die bahamas
zugezogen und es ist jetzt so dass er
wahrscheinlich an der küste entlang von
florida nach nord nordosten zieht über
dem wasser das bedeutet allerdings
flutwellen dort von vier bis sechs meter
höhe
ich wünsche noch einen schönen abend und
machen sie's gut